you know I'd kill him now is so bad we
call him basic Billy Chris Mullin I
would be embarrassed after that to be
fair you would wha how it's unbelievable
I I'm Luke Shaw and this is sport Bibles
raped my skills oh my god free time it's
so bad not being horrible bit looks like
the other guy don't really play football
but see nada Killian now for the third
one dead
Herrera loves that one he always tries
it in training he tried doing it to me
over there and I didn't let him do it
and we had we nearly had a little fight
to be fair not laughs I've an argument
because I don't like it when someone
tries that so I go aggressive on the
pitch he's an animal but off the pitch
is a nice guy oh my god I can't even say
anything bad about that is all four is
so bad tonight I sense someone in
training do that before we cook we call
him we call him basic Billy that's his
nickname for us is Chris Smalling his
nickname his nicknames basic Billy but
not for football for someone else play
it's taken in to that but he's he's done
something like this before I would be
embarrassed after that to be fair you
were and he's probably angry so he sees
all his mates loved him
[Music]
Oh haha house unbelievable
how old is this guy that's unbelievable
what's the wall doing though they've got
a stand there and be strong you know and
then uh she's got that all day rush hood
I wouldn't want to be in front of rushes
no chance he strikes it so even side
foot when he strikes it he's unbelieving
always faced finish it yes unbelievable
Bala I've seen him take top or he's
horrendous at food
he's so rad but he practiced him every
day so I'm sure he's gonna get better
I wouldn't put basic Billy on that I
don't need to say his name everyone
knows who basic Villiers
[Music]
you know I'm not gonna live had that
done to me before and rainin Matteo Dom
Ian yeah I tried booting Matteo after
during the session I got Meigs again so
it was a bad day for me
[Music]
Jessie's done that before you've
probably seen the picture but Jessie
Jessie does it good serves him right
though for being so cocky actually I
shouldn't be doing now my top three
would be the one with the free nut mix
it was good skill but the defender
didn't really you know look to baa birds
but it was still very nice my number two
would that would be the skill in the
corner the one that I said her I've had
done to me before the best for me it
would have to be the one that hit the
crossbar and went in a great strike and
obviously the kid looks young as well
and you know the keeper I mean I had no
chance of saving it so you know that was
an amazing strike and I'd be my my top
one I'm Luke Shaw and this was rape my
skills
[Music]
you